bonsoir nouvelle édition du 7 8 sport
chaque semaine 26 minutes pour faire le
tour de l'essentiel du sport de sept
dernières 48 heures avec anthony bonsoir
bonsoir wilfried bonsoir à tous et au
programme aujourd'hui nous allons
revenir sur les deux titres historiques
de champion de france de boxe de marvin
petit et de adila mohammadi qui est avec
nous sur ce plateau tous les deux
licenciés au boxing club de saint
quentin et je recevrai également franck
saunier l'entraîneur de l'équipe
féminine de tennis de table d'élan cours
qui évoluent en pro b nous ferons un
petit bilan après la fin de la phase
aller et une phase aller qui a été
plutôt correct
et puis comme d'habitude en fin
d'émission tous les résultats du
week-end la team farrugia excellent
résultat ce week-end félicitations faut
tout d'abord félicitations boxeur
également vous pouvoir passer le message
à marvin petit bard d'ailleurs les
images du combat expéditif tout à l'air
de marvin petit oui tout à fait on va on
va faire un petit mot tout d'abord avec
adila bonsoir a dit là vous êtes à
nouveau champion de france de celle et
chez les super-moyens c'est une belle
satisfaction
oui oui c'était l'objectif aussi de
pouvoir remettre notre ceinture en jeu
et puis voir en gros
enfin voilà confirmé le statut de
champion de france
l'entraîneur est jamais loin mon 100
tonnes par an via c'est aussi une belle
fierté pour l'entraîneur absolu cette
ceinture absolument non seulement ce
sont des grands boxeurs sont des gens
adorables sont des gens formidables très
intelligent il a du mal à s'exprimer
parce qu'il a le trac débrouille déjà
sûr c'est un garçon voulait nous faire
croire une seule seconde que nous
impressionner les boxers détrompez vous
je me remets raza sur un ring vous
verrez voilà enfin testé pour vous alors
antoine avant de revenir sur votre
combat aussi a dis là et ces deux titres
historiques je vous propose de revoir
tout le film de cette soirée le combat
daddy là et le combat de marvin petit
avec des images de patrick jacq de
diction ed deggouj la pesée ce dernier
moment avant de monter sur le ring où
les boxeurs se jaugent du regard il leur
reste 24 heures avant de faire parler la
poudre
pendant que les combattants amateurs on
ouvre le bal a dit lahm houmadi entre
peu à peu dans son combat à l'abri des
regards
son entraîneur antoine farrugia délivre
ses derniers conseils cette deuxième
confrontation face à cédric bellais que
les longs pour toi déjà battue en 2010
commence par un round d'observation dès
la seconde reprise le comorien d'origine
est plus offensif que son adversaire il
contrôle le cogneur tahitien qui n'a pas
les armes pour le faire tomber
adila mohammadi est déclaré vainqueur à
l'unanimité des juges
il conserve sereinement son titre
national des super moyens jeu à partir
du second au second j'ai commencé à
saisir la stratégie qui avait pu mettre
en place ensuite moi
je sais basé sur la mienne sans
forcément prendre de risque et
puis on a fait le combat comme ça sans
prendre de risque on agirait combats du
début à la fin j'ai pour le dernier
combat le palais des sports d'el en
cours est prêt à exploser à l'image de
l'invaincu marvin petit il ne connaît
pas son adversaire joël durand mais le
jeune boxeur il encourt toit est prêt on
a un peu stressé c'est c'est normal il
ya un peu de stress mais bon un coup
comme monter sur le ring c'est sa part
c'est un ici parti veut un combat de
marvin petit part dès son entrée dans la
salle
à chacune de ses sorties le protégé
d'antoine farrugia assurent le spectacle
prêts à faire tomber l'adversaire qui va
se présenter devant lui sur le ring et
comme un signe
il arbore déjà le short tricolore les
spectateurs vont d'ailleurs en avoir
pour leur argent
la foudre s'abat sur joël durand en
quelques secondes
soirée historique pour le boxing club de
saint quentin désormais le seul club
français à posséder deux champions de
france dans ses rangs
attila on vient de voir le sujet et puis
les images de votre combat vous avez été
très serein samedi soir c'est un peu ce
qui ressort de ce combat pour la
ceinture de champion de france
oui ce sera plus ou moins après
c'était par rapport à la préparation
qu'on a pu mettre en place avec antoine
farrugia donc
danger j'avais confiance en ce qu'on
faisait donc j'étais prêt physiquement
et mentalement et en plus c'était un
adversaire que vous connaissiez puisque
cédric bellais vous l'aviez battue en
2010 et sur à rennes et des arbitres
donc il y avait aussi cette certaine
assurance de la victoire précédente
aussi aussi mais bon on ne sait pas
forcément basé dessus parce que bon deux
ans écoulés au s'il a pu progresser j'ai
pu progresser
donc il fallait vraiment se baser sur
notre nouvelle stratégie et puis savait
exactement c'était quoi cette nouvelle
stratégie antoine bell hip hop et je me
suis battu non je m'étais doutait que ce
garçon avait évolué et qu'il avait
progressé à ce qu'il a fait compter un
peu les salles américaines
donc je me suis dit il a forcément
progresser puis il faut jamais
sous-estimer les gens en face de vous
donc je me doutais qu'il avait bien
évolué et donc comme un garçon n'est pas
en reste non plus il a bien évolué aussi
je me suis dit ça va faire un beau
combat
il a été touché comme ou deuxième il
s'est pris une bonne droite
c'est ce que je vais demander ça vous
avait des reproches alors faire de
combattants de ce week end parce que
excusez moi la droite qui prend pas tout
le monde peut la prendre n'importe qui
c'est la boxe
à chacun sa stratégie note il a joué sur
un coup il a failli réussir il a failli
et bon après le combat c'était a été
clair je suis à gérer comme il l'a voulu
il a fait ce qu'il a voulu
oui bon je vous l impression qu où
justement ça vous a déstabilisé ne
serait ce que dans la tête par exemple
vous vous êtes dit
senti plus fragiles en tout cas pas du
tout non pas forcément senti plus
fragiles fragile là dessus de l'épaule
mais tout simplement dit bah ne va pas
chercher plus est contente toi de ce
qu'il fallait faire donc prendre mes
distances se bat prendre de risques et
puis de faire complète carrément la
différence sur chaque round
voilà il gagné tous ces routes
stratégiques mentez jaman et puis
sûrement surtout ça vous a bien réussi
voilà et en plus bizarrement cédric
bellais n'a pas été offensif comme un
challenger qui veut vraiment croquer du
champion ça a été il était très très sur
le reculoir en fin de compte après c'est
vrai que
je je je
je rejoins peu ce que vous dites
j'attendais à avoir un cédric bellais
qui aurait été beaucoup plus offensif
parce que j'ai pu la voir sur le premier
combat qu'on a pu faire ensemble mais il
a été en tout cas il était peut-être
méfiant maintenant c'est le public qui a
fait la différence possible que la salle
du palais des sports mécaniques
mais là encore qui a dû faire un
différents événements violents combats
chacun bien donc
mais bon sinon sans ça il a fait le
combat qu hélas il a fait un bon combat
aussi quoi donc là c'est la deuxième
fois que vous gardez la ceinture la
première fois vous l'aviez vous l'aviez
conquise mesdames vous la garder fermée
vous confirmez ce titre de champion de
france des super moyens
on va on va revenir un peu à octobre 1
s'était fait championnat d'europe c'est
on y pense déjà on se dit on va essayer
d'aller chercher un nouveau un nouveau
combat une nouvelle chance pour la
ceinture de champion d'europe
oui pourquoi pas maintenant là
l'opportunité s'offre à moi je la saisis
avec avec plaisir je l'attends qu'en
pensent-ils internet je pense que
malheureusement nos manuels un coup de
chance
la première fois parce qu'il était pas
connue il rappelle l'effet de surprise
voilà et on vous appellera pas de sitôt
je ne pense pas sincèrement je connais
milieu de la boxe et je peux vous dire
que il a essayé une trop grosse
impression et les anglais ont été très
choqués et je ne pense pas qu'ils nous
rappellent ils auraient trop peur de
perdre ce titre je pense qu'ils savent
très bien que ça très dur pour le pour
le boxeur et j'évite roncquois c'est
difficile ça de se dire qu'il ya une
possibilité de gagner mais pour y aller
ça va après monsieur c'est une question
de promoteurs ce une question d'argent
donc si on a une ville une région qui
nous soutient à nous si on peut
organiser mais là comme j'ai vu que ça
court très vite dans la région dépend
demandé sous dix jours
je commence à désespérer sincèrement et
pourtant il ya du monde parce qu'ils
avaient encore beaucoup le fait que vous
ayez deux boxeurs être le seul le seul
club à avoir deux boxeurs champion de
france ça va être aidé pour avoir un
combat côté du web cependant le souhaite
mais ce que je voudrais dire à ces gens
responsables cukor lorsqu ils promettent
quelque chose ils tiennent leurs
promesses
et quand ils disent non et qu'il le dise
tout de suite et pas faire ce qui nous
en fait c'était le cas je vais vous
demander vous avez eu des promesses de
subventions
après sept et douze minutes après c'est
et 5000 à l'arrivée c'est zéro et ça
c'est conseil général moi je trouve que
c'est déplorable un conseil général
quand nous avons dans 78 je sais pas qui
est responsable de ça mais je le
félicite pas là pour le coup de ça on va
dire dire et il s'intéressait à un autre
combat pour revenir sur un plan sportif
également celui marine petit oui marvin
petit qui a été expéditif tout
simplement aura pas d'autres termes un
peu près de 40 secondes de combat
on le savait invaincu avant avant ce
combat d'ailleurs je vous propose de
regarder parce que ça va partir mais ça
l'intégra vicieux du combat
l'intégralité du combat que vous êtes il
faut que les téléspectateurs soit très
attentif parce que sa batterie mais je
vous éloignez pas de votre poste ça va
très très vite oui
robert présent
et voilà pour la c'est la première
reprise
un premier direct une première approche
on va dire de marvin si vous voulez
aussi vous voulez commenté antoine
n'hésitez pas non je ne découvre les
images comme vous mais franchement rien
premier direct du droit qui à gauche
arrive ça et là c'est le coup de grâce
et la levée d'un combat parfait la
première de même pas parfait en fait il
alors c'est difficile pour lui ce
dossier mais c'est vrai que quand
j'étais venu suivre votre préparation
avoué adila et à marvin martin mais
avait tout de suite dit je sais que je
peux le toucher en un coup bas on a vu
la preuve en image hein je crois c'était
et il est impressionnant et je crois que
sa réputation va vraiment grandir combat
après combat non ils sont tous les deux
bonhommes et sur la france et d'europe
et bien sûr on est en point de mire pour
certaines personnes c'est normal mais
sincèrement je pour l'instant je suis
tranquille ils peuvent venir n'y ait
aucun problème
la suite or pour marine justement on va
essayer de défendre notre ceinture selon
des propositions qu'on va nous faire
bien sûr
puis c'est pas intéressant on n'y va pas
mais si c'est intéressant et aucun
problème fort a dit là je ne sais pas
encore mais je pense qu'on va pas tarder
à lâcher la nature parce qu'on a
d'autres objectifs
c'est un garçon qui a qu'il peut se
permettre d'avoir d'autres objectifs par
exemple international déjà et puis
pourquoi pas une chance mondiale
1 pourquoi pas il a fait un championnat
d'europe donc on peut se permettre tout
est permis
plein d'espoir encore pour ce club team
farrugia et des bons résultats surtout
pour les acteurs parce qu'il le mérite
et ils sont ils sont la hauteur de ce
qu'ils font sont pas des gens qui
manquent d'ambition et ils ont ils ont
ils ont droit d'avoir des ambitions vous
n'êtes pas venu avec la ceinture oui
malheureusement elle est allée à les
décharger le jour mettant n'y a pas trop
de mal
désolé pour reviendrai sur ce plateau
pour nous présenter cette ceinture très
personnelle je n'irai pas jusqu'à vous
dire qu'on ira la chercher
la nationale sympa l'avenir le plus
proche est quand même un peu de vacances
adil rami n'est pas d'accord tous les
deux merci d'être venu sur le plateau de
tv fils ce soir oui c'est important
chaîne en panne et sans transition de
tennis 1 malgré malgré le froid et les
chutes de neige il ya encore des
compétitions indoor un pendant cet hiver
qui continue c'est le cas du tournoi de
tennis de la verrière qui a commencé le
12 janvier dernier l'open d'ailleurs
fait ces dix années
ses dix bougies cette année il
l'occasion de faire le point avec
patrick jacques de dixmude
si vous cherchez un tournoi de tennis en
plein mois de janvier
pensez à la verrière l'open fête
d'ailleurs ses 10 ans cette année mais
les structures du club ferriérois sont
limitées l'association ne disposant que
de deux terrains couverts les 128
adhérents du club ne peuvent donc pas
jouer pendant cette période
l'organisation devient vite un vrai
casse tête
on limite le nombre de joueurs pour ce
tournoi on a 150 joueurs 45 femmes 105
hommes dans la semaine on établit six
matchs par soir il s'avère que les
joueurs de la région parisienne
finissent tard donc on ne peut commencer
dès match qu'après leur travail c'est à
dire 18 heures et on finisse fort tard
malheureusement fait n'est souvent à
minuit à la création du tournoi les
responsables du club cherchait un
créneau où il n'y avait pas d' open pour
ne pas subir la concurrence d'autres
compétitions le mois de janvier devient
vite une évidence limité en classement
et en nombre de joueurs l'accueil reste
une priorité qui séduit les compétiteurs
j'habite pas très loin ça doit faire un
troisième quatrième fois que je fais le
tournoi le club est assez sympa et
j'aime bien bien fait à ce tournoi qui
est limitée dans les classements très
bien très très courtois très conviviale
très aimable non c'est pas ça que j'aime
bien les tournois qui sont pas trop trop
grand parce que justement il ya un côté
beaucoup plus convivial qu'on n'a pas
dans les grands tournois donc j'apprécie
cet or noir
avec les fortes chutes de neige six
rencontres ont été reportées
rendez vous tout de même le 3 février
prochain pour les phases finales du
tennis au tennis de table à présent dans
le 7-8 sports anthony oui nous devions
recevoir franck saunier mais qui lors
d'un entraîneur des féminines
d'elancourt
en tennis de table qui évolue en pro b
mais malheureusement franck et et
bloquées par les chutes de neige sont
climatiques difficiles on les fusillades
et des conditions climatiques très
difficiles donc il est avec nous
heureusement par téléphone bonsoir
franck donc vous inviter pour faire un
petit bilan de mi saison après la phase
aller du championnat
on s'était vus en début de saison et
vous m'aviez dit bon l'objectif c'est le
maintien
et pour l'instant troisièmes après cette
phase aller c'est plutôt satisfaisant
satisfaisant pardon et le maintien est
déjà en poche non à la place de 3e est
vraiment flatteur pour nous on fut
attendais pas trop fait vraiment une
bonne nouvelle puisque à la fin de la
phase aller on reste dans le trio de
tête fait vraiment la bonne nouvelle
pour la première saison mais le pied qui
comme qui fidèles à leurs principes
maintenant presque
en définitive le niveau de la poule est
très relevée pour quelque chose
on a réussi à perdre contre l'avant
dernier pour dire que le niveau de jeu
des équipes que l'on rencontre et a fait
retirer et dans les quatre premières
places
trois des quatre équipes qui se tiennent
en moins c'est ce qu'on se disait en
préparant les missions c'est que cette
année cette saison-là la pro b à n'a
jamais autant aux truites et de joueuses
étrangères
c'est un peu le marché de l'étranger qui
arrive dans le championnat de france
complètement y avait beaucoup de jeux de
pays comme la grève comme
et puis et puis où vous arrêter pour un
championnat qui puis devant le fait de
remporter deux noms pénigaud et devient
de plus en plus et alors par rapport à
cette phase retour les championnats le
championnat donc reprend ses droits
est ce que il ya des matches clés sur
cette phase retour vous avez coché des
dates importantes allant des matches
importants et surtout à ne pas le faire
donc rentable falloir qu'on peut quand
même faire match nul des matches clés
pour être le premier déjà contre le club
fournit bancaire française que l'on va
recevoir le 19 février le foie vous
voyez donc sa fin des matches importants
et les matches peuvent arriver bien et
aller parce qu'on a commencé par eux et
on avait fait des niches les 4 à 2 dont
il était en attendait pas subir des
variations finale femmes et donc le
match retour va être important après il
ya des matches comme echirolles et de la
banlieue de grenoble où on la gagne 0 à
domicile va falloir
on vit bien ou ou envisager un nul
et puis battre un record comme je
voulais tour qui est tellement dernier
alors fait quand même un code car deux
chambres trois premières farine que le
niveau est très élevé est tout à fait en
quelques mots combien de matchs à peu
près il vous faudrait combien de
victoires il vous faudrait pour pour
assurer ce maintien qui a encore un
petit peu indécis je pense que si on
arrive avec trois belles victoires et on
est quand même dans le vent mais quoi
elles sont dans le bon wagon
vous êtes dans le bon wagon décrocher et
donc on restera en pro b en tout cas
c'est ce qu'on vous souhaite faire si
franck saunier premier match retour
c'est donc face à saint denis à domicile
et cette équipe de tennis de table des
encours vous l'avez rencontré anthony
oui tout à fait on était venu les voir
en tout début de saison avec elodie
moines pour faire le portrait de cette
équipe puisque ils encourent à recruter
la numéro 1 grecque ni plus ni moins
maria christopher acquis et des jeunes
pousses qui évolue maintenant en pro b
qui sont des issus du centre de
formation d'elancourt je vous propose de
voir ce portrait avec des images
d'elodie moines
cher il y en avoir lieu avant
d'affronter trois tiers anne-sophie
jantes 18 ans attaquant prochaine du
mari s'est fabriqué des jo et long cou
une équipe de pongistes haï pour gagner
de pénélope saul l'enfant du club et
yanan wang fille de championne du monde
a lieu cet été
le talent ne manque pas et cette saison
la mayonnaise élan courtois se prend
vite amis dans la vie anne-sophie yanan
et iberia habitants colocation et sont
presque inséparables
ouais parce qu'on a par le concours ya
après au niveau est trop tard pour une
eau très bonne ambiance en profite c'est
très bien pour l'équipe
oui super et qui danse comme tout tron
soit tous les jours à l'entraînement
ils veulent bien on essaie de faire des
choses entre nous on doit donc super
s'en va pour la première fois le club et
non courtois prend en charge l'équipe à
100% fini l'entente avec marly-le-roi un
palier passé avec un renfort de choix
maria christophe aura acquis la numéro 1
grecque qui partage son temps entre
elles en cours et le championnat suédois
le club m'a fait une belle proposition
je voulais jouer dans un bon championnat
plus compétitif que la grèce parce que
le championnat grec n'a pas un bon
niveau et l'opportunité de jouer ici
était très intéressante entraîneur
proche de ses filles franzoni apprend à
gérer les égos de ses joueuses avec
diplomatie
je veux les avoir toutes les quatre
ensemble si j'ai des choses à leur dire
je leur dis aux 4 je pense que le
l'autorité chez les filles marchent
moins bien que quand même chez les
garçons on peut être cash
il n'y a pas de problème il nous en
donnerons pas le lendemain on se reparle
ça joue pour les filles il faut être un
peu plus dans le consensus quand même
après la phase aller du championnat
l'équipe de france sony est sur le
podium de pro b
l'objectif maintien du début de saison
est quasiment rempli
l'essentiel du sport les résultats il ya
eu plusieurs rencontres annulées tout de
même ce week-end oui à cause des
intempéries
les fortes chutes de neige de ce
week-end que ça soit en football ou en
rugby
tous les championnats ont été suspendus
les rencontres ont été reportées à la
fin de la saison lorsque le calendrier
le permettra entre deux matches de
championnat isme voix c'était assez
difficile effectivement là mais là ça
doit être compliqué même les mêmes les
crampons vissés ça devait être conseillé
de jouer au football mais en bal en
revanche un ca à jouer puisqu'on est en
indoor en intérieur et les féminines de
montigny-le-bretonneux sont allés
chercher une victoire très précieuse sur
le terrain de landi lampaul autres
concurrents pour le maintien en
nationale 2 les joueuses de stéphane
paysans se sont imposés 26 à 23 et rando
remonte à la huitième place de leur
poule de nationale 2 avec désormais six
points d'avancé sur le premier relégable
tennis de table on en parlait il ya
quelques instants avec les pro b est
féminine et l'encours et on y revient
pour lyon reprise du championnat de
france que cette fois ci en nationale 2
pour la première journée de cette
seconde phase puisque les phase dure six
mois en nationale 2 il fallait et évolue
à domicile pour l'emporter
aucune victoire à l'extérieur l'équipe 2
des l'encours s'est imposée 10 à 4 face
à père signé mais les féminines de
voisins bretons ne se sont inclinés sur
le terrain de poitiers 10 à 5 au
classement fontenay prend la tête de
cette poule c avec un gamin goal avérage
eux favorables et l'encours est 3e et
l'entente de voisins saint-arnoult ferme
la marche à égalité de points avec
périgné nîmes
mais après une journée à wilfrid ce
n'est pas encore très significatif il
reste encore beaucoup de chemin
prochain match le 2 février voisin
recevra le leader fontenay et l'encours
se déplacera à la trinité on va là pour
le classement du tennis de table qui
vient de s'afficher on passe à présent
au volley ball
la rencontre entre l'ès montini volée et
noisy le grand a été reportée au 6 1
malgré l'intérêt le sport en intérieur
les visiteurs n'ayant pu se déplacer
jusqu'au complexe pierre de coubertin le
report est prévue le week-end du 9 10
février quand à plaisir ville preuve le
leader se déplaçait à puch et s'est
incliné lourdement 3 sets à 0 sans
vraiment existé à une défaite vraiment
sévère 25 16 25 19 et 25 23
au classement les yvelinois scène avec
cette défaite la tête du championnat de
régionale une âme à camou et se retrouve
deuxième avec 26 points
l'aes montini volley ball est désormais
6e mais peut encore accrocher la
quatrième place synonyme de playoffs
si les inhumant teint réaliste un sans
faute jusqu'à la fin de la saison le
vendée globe qui se poursuit encore et
toujours toujours
et presque à la fin la wilfrid après 72
jours de cons c'est toujours françois
gabart qui mène la flotte il ne lui
reste plus que 1800 milles environ à
parcourir avant les sables d'olonne il
devrait franchir la ligne d'arrivée ce
week-end
il est à l'heure actuelle dans
l'anticyclone des açores pour tanguy de
lamotte notre marin versailles et il est
toujours installé en onzième position
il longe les côtes argentines et remonte
très fort sur le 10e bertrand de broc
avec une vitesse moyenne de 20 noeuds
mais vendredi le skipper d'initiative
coeur a percuté un ofni un objet
flottant non identifié
un accident qui a abîmé le safran du
bateau le safran c'est la petite qui qui
permet de guider un tout simplement le
catamaran mais qui ne perturbe pas cet
accident ne perturbe pas pour l'instant
la déviation de tanguy de lamotte qui
est donc 11e et le prochain point bien
sûr ce sera lundi prochain chaque lundi
18h30 en direct le 7 8 sport n'hésitez
pas à commenter le 7-8 sport sur sur
twitter et nous donner tous les
résultats de vos clubs via internet via
un vieux par mail et à lundi prochain
bonne soirée la fin du set 8 sport est
aussi fin du set 8 pour ce soir demain
mardi dès 18h en direct il sera question
des négociations entre syndicats et
renault après l'annnonce de 7500
suppressions de postes en france d'ici à
deux ans et puis de la ryder cup
également nous parlerons l'événement
sportif se prépare déjà à saint quentin
en yvelines
ce n'est qu'en 2018 mais un comité dédié
vient d'être lancée excellente soirée
soyez bien évidemment prudence sur les
routes avec la neige
à demain